developing a vaccine typically takes
around 10 years and can cost up to a
billion dollars but as the Ebola
epidemic ravages West Africa and spreads
into the Western world
researchers are rushing to find a cure
you know this is an infectious diseases
War the worst outbreak in history the
need for these countermeasures of course
is more keenly felt at this point in
time here at the Walter Reed Army
Institute of research doctors like
Colonel Steven Thomas and Colonel Sean
Remick are fast tracking human Trials of
a promising vaccine we did in about six
weeks what would normally take about six
months so far the vaccine's animal data
has been outstanding proving to protect
100 of monkeys from Ebola but unlike
mainstream vaccines there is no Ebola
virus in the actual injection in instead
it contains a cow virus engineered to
look like Ebola to the immune system as
it replicates it was a live virus would
it puts on a coat that looks like Ebola
the body says Ah you look like Ebola and
it mounts a response to it that response
will be remembered we hope the biggest
challenge for researchers is that they
can't determine the vaccine's efficacy
by exposing people to Ebola during the
trial process that means the vaccine can
only be tested for safety if you do not
go through this process of product
development and you skip steps you
potentially put people at risk for harm
and you potentially put out products
that may not work and not only may not
work but actually may make the situation
worse over the course of the trial the
doses are bumped up and volunteers are
monitored for side effects what we're
really watching for is safety signals do
you have joint pain do you have muscle
pain headaches so far the vaccine
appears to be safe and strong
preliminary data is expected in December
but even if it moves quickly through the
clinical trials there's still no
guarantee the vaccine will actually work
that's the million dollar question real
real will we have effective vaccines for
this particular outbreak it's very
difficult to tell